have you gone free child cold outside
home free cold with you run off to I'm
here free child right here you call and
you've no place to go you mine sweet
child o mine to run homes which I'll run
home no you no place to go
this piece of missing dialogue almost
certainly belongs to the crawling tree
who is unique amongst all our sisters
for as you approach in game you can hear
her weep
and it's the same sound present in the
missing dialogue you just had so we're
left wondering who then is her sweet
child with no place to go
guarded by the tree is snap free one of
the two spells left behind by the young
sorceress Sullivan it reads
Sullivan was born and raised inside the
painting yet had little used for his
frigid homeland since he had not yet
experienced loss his references his
birth his upbringing and all that next
to a tree that talks about a sweet child
who has disappeared
of course it doesn't all add up it
doesn't make sense that the tree is
outside yes talks about it being cold
outside it doesn't make sense that items
say Sullivan has no place to go yet the
tree tells him to run home I'll be
honest I just wanted a segue to talk
about Sullivan because we didn't
actually get a chance to talk about him
in the previous videos we learn a little
bit more about him in the paintings and
I think it might help us understand the
man he became for the painted world is
essentially one big mirror to the
linking of the fire it was no surprise
that Sullivan may have been quick to
grasp the nature of the outside world
within the painting the residents pride
themselves on their ability to paint a
new world when their existing world has
fallen to rot and in a way Sullivan sets
out to do that same thing on the outside
the outside to its rotting to these
endless ages of fire and Sullivan does
fight against that in a way because he
joins forces with oldrich this being who
has dreamt of an end to the age of fire
and of the beginning of the age of the
deep sea we'll get to that in a second
going back to the painting while he was
there Sullivan was classed as a young
sorcerer with sorceries that were
clearly inspired by his homeland
however the items read ironically he did
not belong in this place of belonging as
he had
not yet experienced loss unlike the
others in the painting so he left for a
similar environment but a different
world aerosol located in the boreal
valley was where he discovered the
profaned flame deep below where he found
his ambition where he became the pontiff
eventually usurping the old gods from
anor londo and eventually taking the
frozen city for his own he then goes on
to provide refuge for Aldrich a lord of
cinder who abandoned his duty to link
the fire and even offers him gwyndolin a
god of the old royalty to devour and I
think knowing his origins flesh out the
character a little bit more they help us
understand the man who settled in era
Phil why he might have rejected the
rotten linking of the fire and
eventually how he probably wanted to be
a part of a new world just like the core
beings of the painting moving on this is
a texture of the murals in re and L
courtesy of Manoa Barton on Twitter now
Jake the ash and Hollow
managed to find some hidden text in this
texture I'm going to give you a few
seconds and see if you can find it too
it's here
forgive my pronunciation but sassou mono
told negative Cebu Sumana roughly
translates to stabber and crusher
stabber and crusher thanks to our
resident translator law master Naga once
again for that so the discovery of this
collaborative treasure hunt is that the
two figures are clearly called
stabber and crusher perhaps internally
by from software which is probably not
intended for our knowledge to be honest
you'd think it's just their name but it
revealed that the act of stabbing and
crushing might be an important part of
the mural as well as making it clear
that what they're stabbing and what
they're crushing is alive which is very
significant because it essentially
confirms to me that the two white things
are most likely snakes as you guys
suggested in an earlier video because
why would you stab or crush something
it's not living right plus there are two
entwined serpents engraved upon the
doors to the chapel so three questions
arise for me what are the Sphinx who are
the figures and why are they stabbing
and crushing the snakes snakes are most
likely primordial servants it's its best
because there are two here and because
these two snakes would line up perfectly
with the two prominent primordial
serpents in the game cast and Frant who
both represented aside of linking the
fire in Dark Souls one friends pushed
you to sacrifice yourself for the flame
and calf wanted you to watch it die he
wanted you to usher in the next stage of
man and these two snakes and light and
dark
they're always entwined somehow just
like the two on the door and it does
make some sense for these two serpents
to be represented in re and L for this
is the DLC where miyazaki has attempted
to display the linking of the fire from
another perspective so now who are the
figures both of whom are fairly seminal
I'd like to say that they're the two
other sisters of disable Church freedom
being the third but as we've already
seen two other sisters and we know that
their masks don't look anything like
this that assumption definitely comes
with some contradictions so I personally
think that as of yet they are
unmentioned characters in the game
they're defining characteristics r1 has
a straight thin sword another has an
ended arm reaching down to the snakes
coming from the dark who are likely the
primordial serpents hollows in wreathed
in flame reach out towards them to help
perhaps in this pose that is so familiar
to other praying hollows in the game and
if these are primordial serpents that
makes these two characters Hugh
by comparison and probably powerful too
and the third question why are they
stabbing and crushing the snakes well if
we assume that the snakes are cast and
frampt then killing them might represent
animosity for the linking of the fire
which is something that both cars and
Frant represent in a way as each serpent
pushes you to either link the fire or
you serve it and Frieda is unconditional
to link or you serve to fire and she
fled to the painting after that failure
in my opinion she'd be quite okay with
the deaths of friend or car and the
depiction of them within this place
makes a bit of sense with that context
of course just because I've mentioned
the most likely explanations doesn't
mean it's right next the woman in the
tens of paintings scattered around
Frida's chamber I think it's clear that
it's Frieda herself depicted at the
location and the pose is the same as
where and how she sits in real life
hands clasped with a round table by her
side it's like she's posing for these
pictures which were presumably done by
the painter upstairs but why have so
many done well there is something
special about the paintings made by the
painter since she is responsible for
creating the next world
maybe Frieda wanted to affirm her
position here in this world with a bit
of the painters power but we know she
sent this painter away eventually maybe
she wasn't happy with her depiction in
these works maybe it has something to do
with the fire that encroaches around to
the edges of each painting the fire was
unavoidably linked to Frieda no matter
how much she despised it she couldn't
separate herself from it in the end in
one picture in particular Frieda holds a
tablet in her bandaged hands with a
knight depicted upon it
this Knight has a helm that's unlike
anything we've seen in game
but it also has what looks like the
woollen cauldrons of the firaon set and
what looks like the plume of the
nameless King behind it I'm reaching
here those two things are related to
each other but I'm still reaching we
were never meant to look this closely at
this mystery night I think so for now I
guess I'll just keep an eye out for
anything looking like this in the future
although it does bring to mind
yuria dialogue saying that we should
remember those that stayed by Frida's
side until the very end I think it would
make more sense for little helm to be
picked it in this picture rather than
miss mystery night but that's just my
take finally the textures reveal a burn
on Frida's face and along with the
bandages in the paintings that are
around her hands maybe these are burn
marks from linking the fire and failing
perhaps more questions remain that might
never get answered questions like what
is the abyss dragon mentioned in the
downfall of the Millwood Knights
what is the snake statue hidden at the
back of REM Belle's chamber and what is
the Dark Soul of man which is the
biggest cliffhanger a piece of DLC has
ever left us on I think as from prepares
this final piece of DLC to the dark
souls series and as if increasingly
looks like we're going to visit a city
of hollows I think that we're going to
have to come to terms with the fact that
we may never have these questions
answered for sure but regardless it's
been damn fun speculating and just
before I go I want to say that we
actually have more of a community
starting over on patreon right now so
everyone who gives a dollar now has
access to the discord channel which has
been so much fun there's a place you can
show off your art like Emily Dickinson's
work you can see here there's general
discussion there's law discussion you
can link music pictures if you're
looking for a Dark Souls community to be
a part of I'm having a blast with this
and I'm adding a few more perks
- so $5 patrons can now be polled to
help me decide what direction to take
the channel and I've even started to
upload the notes that I make my videos
based off
which are for beacon patrons these notes
have color-coded research on dialogue
item descriptions environments and
basically if you want access to the
rough unedited core of my videos then
this tier might be interesting to you
but thank you for supporting me whether
you're a patron or you're not a patron
it's all good thank you for watching
this and I'll see you next time